la crise n'atteint pas tous les secteurs
1 million d'euros supplémentaires
consacrés au tourisme dans le
département 1 million pour renforcer les
services offerts sur internet à commencé
par ce blog ouvert pour la première
édition dédiée au randonné vers les
Yvelines du 18 mai au 2 juin il y a un
blog qui lui est consacré qui peut-être
aujourd'hui consulté on peut même
contribuer si on le souhaite si on est
un fan de rendonné euh ensuite nous
aurons des des euh des propositions sur
les idées de sortie et puis on ira aussi
vers les idées de séjour pour des
visiteurs qui sortent qui ont envie de
rester un petit peu plus longtemps dans
le
département le secteur du tourisme dans
le département cela représente 5700
entreprises et 23700 emplois avec une
particularité franilienne la part du
tourisme d'affaires dans les ivelines
occupe 70 % et sur ce marché la crise se
fait ressentir une entreprise euh bah
rchigne a dépensé beaucoup d'argent dans
un séminaire quand euh quand quand
l'activité à côté n'est pas très très
fructueuse donc on baisse un petit peu
les budgets on reporte les séminaires
très souvent mais on a des
établissements hôteliers de de grande
qualité qui se battent beaucoup qui sont
extrêmement dynamiques nos dispositifs
sont là aussi pour les aider on a un
site qui sortira en septembre qui
s'appelle des idées de de séjour d'où
l'idée de multiplier les sites internet
et donc les cibles yvelinois franilien
européens devrai y trouver des idées
pour sortir découvrir or le séjour
500000 connexions sont espérées d'ici 2
ans le département accueille chaque
année 16 millions de tourismes dont 100
millions rien que pour le château de
Versailles